moi avec mon portable de mer pas de
problème tout
[Musique]
monsieur jacques chimique n est pas
exprès vous attendez sagement ernest
vous faites car mon semblant d'avoir
peur ce qu'on peut plus jouer plus mal
j'en sais rien karim adda écouter faire
pipi nettoie non surtout pas je vais
aller faire pipi
parce que je me touche le plus bien joué
merci est-ce que tu sais comment c'est
des pâtes commerce et surtout tu veux
plus de 20
une demande de verser à 219 envisage que
rendu que je vis depuis que j'ai eues
dans cet hôtel j'ai déchaussé je parle
comme bruce willis
[Musique]
paquereau monarchie
les tchèques ont inventé pour toi seront
de fantômes de merde te souviens-tu
chaud sous merde allez oui oui tiens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bizarre
en gros il faudrait que tu fasses
quelque chose de vraiment c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment vraiment vraiment
[Rires]
c'est parce que je parle en mon nom je
peux parler en stéréo bas à gauche
droite gauche droite mais au moins je
suis en 3d moi tu veux un café est-ce
que tu le veux ce qu'a fait le désir
déguste avant m'a dit beaucoup de bien
de tous
[Musique]
c'était quelqu'un de grand à l'intérieur
tu vas pas la taille c'est pas le 2
laisse personne dire que tu es une
barque va aussi vite qu'un paquebot
enfin la pao vite parce que la barque où
peut aller au final aussi vite que le
gros sexe que le paquebot je tiens à
m'excuser
[Musique]
il parlait du bateau en fait c'était
pour mon sexe parce que j'avais un petit
sexe tu le prends du vin ou non
[Musique]
nickel comment réutiliser un mec ans
mauguio depuis psychose on a tous un peu
peur des douches n'hésite pas te malmène
comme ça tu mad men comme ça tu jumale
même comme ça si je touche soul à la
codah et si tout ce bruit mais du coup
je pense aller au combat alors tu as
touché sa [__] et divers ne peut
reprendre nettoyer le dealer de prendre
de nettoyer je ne comprenais pas mais
vous disposez très exactement 2 5
secondes pour sauver la terre on avait
prévu pour début vraiment
[Musique]
depuis ça on a tous paris claude tous vu
quoi ça ça
[Rires]
[Musique]